the parched village of odium in
hampshire it had no rain at all in july
and the ground is so hard they're having
to water the cricket pitch several times
a day to make it safe to play the
groundsman has never seen anything like
it our major concern here is that we
will experience a host pipe ban at the
moment we're exempt this area is exempt
at the moment
so we're hoping that you know we can see
the season out before anything does come
into force
but thames water has announced a
hosepipe ban starting within the next
few weeks 15 million people will be
affected from oxfordshire to london
i've never seen
this this part of the river diva
completely dry like this the lack of
rain is also drying up our rivers this
is the diva not far from odium it should
be a bubbling chalk stream one of the
most biodiverse habitats on the planet
but the shrimp are dead and the fish
gone it'll take years to recover
the impact's happening now things are
dying now the the the rivers
comes back in the winter
um you know that that loss is still
there it's going to take a long time for
the populations to to come back and for
the knock-on impact on the whole ecology
to recover
what we've got a totally sterile
environment that is in the last throws
of its life
fergal sharkey was the front man of the
punk band the undertones and is now a
river campaigner he blames water
companies for sucking too much out of
the same underground aquifers that feed
chalk streams leaving little left
for water company chalk water is really
seductive it's a readily available
source of cheap high quality water
right on the age of the biggest
population center in the country water
is big expensive stuff to move around so
from a water company you've now got a
cheap easily accessible supply of water
you don't have to spend much money
treating it before you give it to the
customer
the environment agency said rivers are
exceptionally low in many areas and
reservoir levels falling but it's
hopeful that hosepipe vans will ease
demand
according to the latest data from the
uk's hydrology experts some parts of
central and particularly southern
england now need more than 12
centimeters of additional rainfall to
make up for the dry conditions but there
is nothing in the forecast for august
and no strong signal for a return to our
normal damp weather even up to the end
of october
the met office has issued an amber heat
warning for four days starting on
thursday for parts of england and wales
with temperatures expected to reach as
high as 36 degrees
there's also an ongoing fire risk the
scorching summer shows no sign of coming
to an end
thomas more sky news hampshire